wir sind ja aber wenn der scharia
ordnungsamt wir sind die soften die
lieben ihre lieben wie wir sind die
sympathischen salafisten
[Musik]
man darf die straße nicht der scharia
polizei überlassen es muss auch noch
platz sein für uns das scharia
ordnungsamt
[Applaus]
das amt an nahezu ja gut aber dafür sind
wir ja auch die guten die dafür sorgen
dass es hier mal richtig zug ankommt
leverkusen ist ein sündenpfuhl aber
besonders leverkusen für 800 audi
arbeiten müssen
[Musik]
sie sind ich sehe es gerade sie sind ein
durchschnittlicher leverkusener mit
stimmen der leverkusener bürger aber nur
ein parkplatzwächter parkplatzwächter ja
das ist sicherlich nur neben den sie
hier rauchen vermutlich mal ein
wie heißt das kräuter kräuter der
provence genommen
[Musik]
diese dieser dieser stempel hier und
dieses gesamte stört so ein bisschen
mein sittliches empfinden das gerne hier
bedecken damit dieser schweinkram also
jetzt nicht für jeden offensichtlich
hier so kam der blütenstände kommt so
kommt's sohn kommt er raus und das ist
auch eine unglaubliche sauerei was ist
doch ferkel graf natur das ist ja noch
aber der arme verkäufer nichts dafür
dass die blüte so besteht aber das ist
ja wer diese diese stehen aber erst noch
ein bisschen sie auch dazu die scharia
ordnungsamt dann kann man ja gleich mit
1 8 modell hier die fußgängerzone laufen
finden
das ist so ungefähr das gleiche ist
vergleich hinkt aber gewalt und das will
ich überhaupt nicht mich macht das
schwitzen
das ist für mich das einzige was zählt
versagen mittagspause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
halle ist tommy warum hier sind wohl ein
bisschen nach dem rechten schauen
sie hatten polizisten der polizei die
regel saudischen religion ist für jeden
selbst ja das hat es nicht so dass man
nach außen tragen muss er seine religion
nach außen dringt ist und trotzdem
einher
ja ich werde das noch mal gesagt oder so
religion ist das gefängnis für nun mal
menschen heutzutage gibt es bücher man
kann die schweizer man kann alles
gelesen von der welt jetzt jetzt fangen
die brüder schon mit goethe wir sind wir
sind nicht die von der von der polizei
wir sind hinten drauf stehen scharia
ordnungsamt wir sind nämlich die guten
daher unsere zieht ist noch richtig gut
gottes willen
das ist die treppe herr und frau
dankeschön salafisten also
[Musik]
wir sind jerry aber wir sind der scharia
ordnungsamt wir sind die soften die
lieben ihre lieben wir sind die
sympathischen salafisten ihr seit diesem
jahr gibt es ein paar salafisten oder
was wir gucken mich doch an
noch wird über gott segne dich namen
jesus christus meint hans de schreibt
über die heute show ihr seid die
richtigen links [ __ ] besonders welke
die stradivari unter den arschgeigen bei
euch smileys freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal